WORLD STAGE THAT AND A LOT
MORE AS WE LOOK AHEAD ON "SUNDAY
MORNING FUTURES."
THE CORONAVIRUS PANDEMIC
SPREADING ACROSS THE COUNTRY
FURTHER DISRUPTING DAILY LIVE
NEARLY 3,000 CASES NOW REPORTED
IN 49 STATES AND WASHINGTON D.C.
A TOTAL OF 57 DEATHS WITH THE
MAJORITY IN HALVED HIT
WASHINGTON STATE AS THE HOUSE
PASSED BIPARTISAN EMERGENCY
LEGISLATION TO FIGHT THIS
PANDEMIC AFTER GETTING
PRESIDENT TRUMP’S BACKING IT
GOES NOW TO THE SENATE.
MY FIRST GUEST SAYS WE CAN’T
OVERCOME THIS , HOUSE MINORITY
LEADER KEVIN MCCARTHY, THANKS
FOR JOINING US.
>> THANKS FOR HAVING ME BACK,
MARIA.
MARIA: TELL ME ABOUT THE BILL
THAT WENT SO LATE ON FRIDAY
NIGHT, WHAT IT HAS IN IT AND WHY
IS IT IMPORTANT?
>> WELL WE WENT LATE BECAUSE
THE ORIGINAL BILL THAT SPEAKER
PELOSI PUT WAS JUST NOT WORKABLE
AND AS I SAID ON THURSDAY, WE
SHOULD TAKE A DEEP BREATH, NOT
LEAVE CONGRESS TAKE THE NEXT 24
AND 48 HOURS AND FIX IT AND
ACTUALLY COME TOGETHER, TAKE THE
PART THAT DIVIDE US AND
LET’S UNITE FOR THE AMERICAN
PUBLIC.
WHAT IT DOES IS THREE MAIN THINS
AND MAKES SURE EVERYBODY HAS THE
ABILITY TO GET A TEST IF
THEY NEED IT.
IT ALLOWS FOR SICK LEAVE IF YOU
ARE SICK OR  IF YOU ARE CARING
FOR A LOVED ONE.
IT MAKES SURE THE DEPARTMENT OF
DEFENSE AND THE  VA HAS THE
RESOURCES NEEDED TO CARE FOR
THOSE VETERANS.
I HAD A REAL CONCERN WHAT IT DID
TO SMALL BUSINESS THAT WAS REAL
CHANGES INSIDE THE BILL AND
THAT’S WHY IT CAME LATE.
I WANTED FLEXIBILITY FOR THOSE
SMALL BUSINESSES
ESPECIALLY UNDER 50.
WE HAVE TO MAKE SURE IF YOU’RE
GOING TO MANDATE SMALL BUSINESS
PROVIDE THIS LEAVE HOW CAN THEY
HAVE THE RESOURCES, THE SPEAKER
HAD THE SOCIAL SECURITY DOING IT
, WOULD HARM SOCIAL SECURITY
AND THEY COULDN’T GET IT UP AND
RUNNING AND THE SECOND OF
TREASURY WILL NOW ADVANCE THE
MONEY TO SMALL BUSINESS FOR
THAT QUARTER, TO PAY FOR
THAT SICK LEAVE GOING
FORWARD FOR THIS SHORT TIME
PERIOD MAKING SURE THAT WE HAVE
A TIMETABLE ON THIS , THAT THERE
WAS A SUNSET, AND ALSO DEMOCRATS
HAD PUT UNA NUMBER OF PROVISIONS
THAT WERE JUST PHILOSOPHICALLY
WRONG WITH ANYTHING TO DO HERE
THEY WANTED TO CHANGE THE LAW
AND HAVE TAXPAYER PAY FOR
ABORTION WE MADE SURE WE
TOOK THAT OUT AS WELL.
MARIA: WELL I DON’T UNDERSTAND
YOU HAD ABORTION IN A BILL ABOUT
CORONAVIRUS?
>> YEAH, THE THINGS YOU HAVE TO
WATCH, ESPECIALLY WHEN IT
DOESN’T GO THROUGH COMMITTEE AND
THERE’S A CRISIS.
PEOPLE WILL TAKE THEIR
PHILOSOPHICAL BELIEFS AND TRY TO
RUN THAT THROUGH, WE HAVE THE
AMENDMENT THAT WE HAVE VOTED
ON FOR DECADES I WANTED TO MAKE
SURE THAT PROVISION WAS IN AND I
WANTED TO ALSO MAKE SURE THERE’S
FLEXIBILITY ESPECIALLY FOR THOSE
SMALL BUSINESSES, 50
OR  UNDER, IF THIS IS A HARDSHIP
THAT THEY HAVE THE
OPTION TO GET OUT AND THAT
WAS ONE OF THE LAST PROVISIONS
WE GOT INTO THE BILL.
I WANT TO MAKE SURE PEOPLE HAVE
JOBS TO COME BACK TO.
MARIA: LET ME ASK YOU ABOUT THIS
ARTICLE ON THE FEDERAL LIST
, THE TITLE IS WHY THE
PELOSI WUHAN VIRUS DEAL IS A
NEAR TOTAL GOP SURRENDER, FOR
BLUE COLLAR ENTREPRENEURS
AND THEY ARE ZEROING IN ON WHAT
YOU’RE TALKING ABOUT IN TERMS OF
SMALL AND MID-SIZED BUSINESSES,
AND THEY’RE SAYING THAT WE’RE
GOING TO SEE LAYOFFS ONCE THIS
IS OVER FROM SMALL AND MID-
SIZED BUSINESSES.
THEY NEED ANYTHING THEY CAN
CLING TO TO STAY AFLOAT AND
DELAY FURTHER LAYOFFS THERE’S
NOTHING FOR THEM IN THIS
APPARENT DEAL, NOTHING FOR
THE BLUE COLLAR BUSINESSMAN
THIS COUNTRY’S MIDDLE CLASS WAS
FOUNDED ON EVEN THE $50 BILLION
THAT THE PRESIDENT PREVIOUSLY
ANNOUNCED FOR SMALL BUSINESS ARE
NOT ONLY GOOD FOR BIG BUSINESSES
, WHO CAN GUARANTEE IT
, BUT BAD FOR SMALLER
BUSINESSES.
YOU ARE GETTING SOME PUSHBACK ON
THIS IDEA THAT SMALL AND MID-
SIZE BUSINESSES ARE HAVING
TO PUT OUT THIS BIG COST.
>> WELL, IF THEY READ THE FINAL
VERSION OF THE BILL THEY WOULD
SEE THE FLEXIBILITY THAT THE
SECRETARY HAD.
THE SECRETARY TREASURY WILL
ACTUALLY ADVANCE THE MONEY AHEAD
OF TIME SO THE SMALL BUSINESS
WILL BE ABLE TO HAVE THE
RESOURCES IF THEY HAVE
SOMEBODY ON SICK LEAVE.
REMEMBER THERE’S A SUNSET TIME
PERIOD AND ALSO, REMEMBER WHAT
WE’RE DEALING WITH HERE.
JUST AS THEY SAY WE’VE GOT TO
GET THROUGH THAT PEAK, THAT PEAK
CAN OVERTAKE THE MEDICAL SYSTEM.
THE WATCH WHAT THE WORLD HEALTH
ORGANIZATION RECENTLY SAID THAT
EUROPE IS THE EPICENTER.
WE WANT TO THANK THIS PRESIDENT
FOR THE ACTION HE TOOK EARLY
STOPPING THE FLIGHTS FROM CHINA
ALSO STOPPING THOSE FLIGHTS FROM
EUROPE.
IT IS MAKING AMERICA SAFER SO
HOW DO WE MANAGE ALL THIS GOING
FORWARD?
IF SOMEBODY IS SICK WE WANT TO
MAKE SURE THEY HAVE TESTING.
WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THEY AREN’T
AT WORK PROVIDING AND MAKING
CONTAMINATION TO OTHER
INDIVIDUALS SO WE’VE GOT TO HAVE
THAT SICK LEAVE.
WE KNOW BUSINESSES BEING HURT.
THERE’S NO BASKETBALL GOING ON,
NO MARCH MADNESS, THERE’S NO
HOCKEY GOING ON, PEOPLE ARE
QUARANTINING THEMSELVES WHICH IS
WHAT WE NEED TO DO SO WE NEED
ACTION AND THAT’S WHY WE GAVE
THAT FLEXIBILITY AND THE
ADVANCEMENT OF MONEY.
REMEMBER, AMERICA WORKING
TOGETHER, CAN GET THROUGH
ANYTHING THAT WE NEED AND WE
SHOWED JUST THAT LAST FRIDAY
NIGHT THAT WE CAN, WHAT DIVIDES
US CAN COME TOGETHER FOR THE
AMERICAN PUBLIC AND YOU
WATCH THE ACTION THAT THIS
PRESIDENT TOOK.
EXTRAORDINARY AND HE’S LOOKING
FURTHER AHEAD FROM THE OIL
INDUSTRY, FILLING THE SPUR
BECAUSE IT’S LOWER OIL PRICE,
HELPING THE ENERGY AT THE SAME
TIME, HELPING AMERICA MAKING
SURE NO INTEREST RATES ON THOSE
WHO HAVE STUDENT LOANS,
WE’RE TAKING EVERY POSSIBLE
ACTION THAT THIS IS A MOMENT IN
TIME THAT WE NEED TO COME
TOGETHER AND THAT’S WHY
SUNSETTING IT GIVING SMALL
BUSINESS THE RESOURCES THEY NEED
AND HELP DURING THIS TIME, WE
WILL GET THROUGH THIS TOGETHER
AND WE WILL ACTUALLY BE STRONGER
IN THE END.
MARIA: YEAH, YOU MAKE A GOOD
POINT.
THIS IS A MOMENT IN TIME THAT
ALL HANDS ARE ON DECK.
EVERYONE IS WORRIED ABOUT THIS
PANDEMIC NOW THE WORLD
HEALTH ORGANIZATION IS CALLING
IT SO WHY DID IT TAKE SO LONG TO
GET THIS DONE?
WHY WERE YOU AT WORK AT 1:00
A.M. ON FRIDAY NIGHT?
I MEAN, WHY DID NANCY PELOSI
HAVE SO MUCH DELAY IF THIS IS
SUCH URGENCY?
>> WELL THERE’S A NUMBER OF
REASONS, BUT THE REASON WHY IT
WAS LATE INTO THE NIGHT, I DID
NOT WANT TO SEE A BILL JAM
BECAUSE IT DID NOT GO THROUGH
COMMITTEE.
I WANTED MORE EYES ON IT.
I WANTED THE ABILITY TO WALK
THROUGH EVERY VERSION.
IT’S GOING TO GO TO THE SENATE,
I WAS WORKING WITH SENATOR
MCCONNELL THE LEADER OVER IN THE
SENATE ON NUMEROUS THINGS I
WOULD SEE THAT IT COULD ENHANCE
EVEN FURTHER, WORKING WITH THIS
PRESIDENT, THIS PRESIDENT
HAS TAKEN DECISIVE ACTION EARLY
TO HELP US IN THIS CAUSE OF
WHERE WE’RE WALKING THROUGH,
THIS BILL ADDS TO THAT AT THE
SAME TIME.
YOU WANT TO HAVE TESTING AND I
THINK WHAT THE PRESIDENT HAS
DONE WITH THAT PUBLIC PRIVATE
PARTNERSHIP, EVERY COMMUNITY
EITHER HAS A CVS, A WALGREENS, A
TARGET OR  A WALMART, TO BE ABLE
TO OPEN UP THEIR PARKING LOT TO
HAVE THIS TESTING AND HAVE THE
NEW VERSION OF TESTING GOING
THROUGH, WE HAVE INNOVATIVE
COMPANIES HERE GOING TO HELP US.
YOU LOOK AT WHAT GILLIAD IS
GOING THROUGH WITH THE THERAPY
TREATMENT AND JOHNSON & JOHNSON
AND OTHER COMPANIES TO GET US A
VACCINE.
WE WANT TO WORK THROUGH THIS
TOGETHER.
I REMEMBER THE STORY ABOUT
PRESIDENT KENNEDY WHEN HE
CHALLENGED THIS COUNTRY TO GO TO
THE MOON.
A YEAR LATER HE’S WALKING
THROUGH NASA, HE’S MEETING THOSE
WHO WORK THERE AND RUNS
INTO AN INDIVIDUAL WHOSE A
JANITOR AND ASKS THEM WHAT’S
YOUR JOB AND HE SAYS MY JOB IS
TO PUT A MAN ON THE MOON.
AT THIS MOMENT IN TIME
REPUBLICANS, DEMOCRATS AND ALL
AMERICANS NEED TO COME TOGETHER
AND OUR JOB IS TO MAKE SURE WE
GET THROUGH THIS VIRUS ATTACK
THAT DID NOT COME FROM HERE, AND
MAKE SURE WE’RE SAFE AND WE’RE
GOING TO TAKE ACTIONS WE HAVEN’T
TAKEN BEFORE, AND WE WILL COME
OUT STRONGER JUST AS WE HAVE
BEFORE.
MARIA: SO WHEN WE WERE ON THE
PHONE THIS WEEKEND TALKING
ABOUT THIS INTERVIEW, YOU TALKED
ABOUT THIS VIRUS BEING SORT OF
LIKE IT’S GOING TO GET WORSE
BEFORE IT GETS BETTER AND THEN
MAYBE IT DIES DOWN BUT DO YOU
EXPECT IT COMES BACK IN THE FALL
>> WELL I’M NOT SURE.
WE LEARN SOMETHING MORE EVERY
DAY ABOUT THIS CORONAVIRUS BUT
INFLUENZA NORMALLY IN THE
SUMMERTIME DIPS DOWN AND CAN
COME BACK IN THE FALL.
WHAT WE NEED TO HAVE HAPPEN HERE
IS AS MANY NIH WILL TELL YOU YOU
DON’T WANT TO HAVE SOMETHING TO
OVER RUN A BIG PEAK.
YOU WANT TO LEVEL IT OUT, AS THE
GRASS WOULD SHOW.
ITALY RIGHT NOW IS NOT, DID NOT
HAVE THAT HAPPEN, BECAUSE THEIR
LEADERSHIP DID NOT TAKE THE
ACTIONS THAT PRESIDENT TRUMP
TOOK.
THAT’S WHY THE NEXT FOUR WEEKS
ARE SO CRITICAL.
THAT’S WHY THIS DETERMINATION OF
THE ACTIONS THAT WE ARE MAKING
ARE SMART IN THE LONG RUN.
WE DO NOT WANT OUR HEALTH CARE
SYSTEM THAT’S WHY ELECTIVE
SURGERIES ARE BEING PUSHED ASIDE
THAT’S WHY WE’RE PREPARING AND
DOING THE PUBLIC PRIVATE
PARTNERSHIP, MORE TESTING, THE V
A.
THIS IS MORE VULNERABLE FOR
THOSE WHO ARE OLDER ALL OF
THE INFORMATION THAT WE HAVE,
THE WASHING OF THE HANDS AND
OTHERS, EVERYBODY NEEDS TO BE
WORKING TOGETHER AND I THINK
CONGRESS SHOWED FRIDAY NIGHT.
MARIA: LET ME ASK YOU
CONGRESSMAN BEFORE YOU GO, WE’RE
GOING TO TALK ABOUT THE ECONOMIC
IMPACT OF PETER NAVARRO AND A
LOT OF PEOPLE ARE EXPECTING
RECESSION, I LOVE WHAT THE
PRESIDENT SAID THE OTHER DAY
ABOUT OIL AND BUYING NEW OIL,
WE’RE GOING TO TALK ABOUT THAT
WITH PETER NAVARRO AS WELL BUT
FROM YOUR STANDPOINT IN TERMS OF
GETTING TO A VACCINE IN TERMS OF
PHARMACEUTICAL COMPANIES ARE YOU
WILLING TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
RULES AND REGULATIONS AROUND
THE FDA IN TERMS OF GETTING A
DRUG THROUGH APPROVAL PROCESS
ARE DEALT WITH SOME GETTING A
FAST-TRACK APPROVAL?
>> YEAH, SO THE PRESIDENT HAS
ALREADY TAKEN ACTIONS ON THAT AS
WELL.
WHAT’S UNIQUE TO HEAR IS WE HAVE
HAD SOME CHANGES WITHIN THE FDA
IN THIS TRUMP ADMINITRATION, TO
STREAMLINE, TO MAKE SURE NOTHING
FROM THE BUREAUCRATIC INCIDENCE
IS HOLDING IT UP AND WE’VE GOT A
LOT OF SMART COMPANIES OUT THERE
ALREADY WORKING TOGETHER.
REMEMBER WHEN EBOLA HIT IT WAS
AN AMERICAN COMPANY THAT GOT THE
VACCINE.
WE WERE ABLE TO USE NIH TO MAKE
SURE THAT CONTAINMENT HAPPENED.
UNFORTUNATELY WHEN THIS CRISIS
HIT CHINA HID FROM IT, IN
NOVEMBER IT CAME FORWARD,
PRESIDENT TRUMP ASKED TO SEND
OUR SCIENTISTS AND OUR DOCTORS
OUR VERY BEST RESEARCHERS THERE
THEY WERE NOT ALLOWED TO AND NOW
IT IS A SPREAD ACROSS THE WORLD
BUT THE ACTIONS THAT PRESIDENT
TRUMP HAS TAKEN HAS ACTUALLY
MADE US SAFER, BUT UNFORTUNATELY
, NOW EUROPE IS THE
EPICENTER AND THAT’S WHY THE
ACTION THAT HE TOOK ON THE
FLIGHTS COMING THROUGH,
THAT’S WHY AMERICANS NEED TO
WORK TOGETHER BUT IT HAS TO BE A
PUBLIC PRIVATE PARTNERSHIP AND I
WILL TELL YOU, WE HAVE OVERCOME
THINGS THAT ARE BIGGER BUT THE
NEXT FOUR WEEKS WHERE WE
NEED TO BE SMART, ACT TOGETHER,
AND FIND A WAY THAT WE WILL GET
THROUGH THAT WE WILL NOT
HAVE THAT PEAK BUT MEASURE THIS
OUT AND AT THE END OF THE
DAY YOU AND I WILL TALK
AGAIN ON THIS SHOW AND WE’LL
TALK ABOUT THE INGENUIT Y OF OUR
COMPANIES THAT GOT A VACCINE FOR
IT AND HOW WE WERE PREPARED
AHEAD OF TIME JUST LIKE WE DID
BY INCREASING FUNDING TO THE NIH
AND CDC FOR THE LAST
FOUR YEARS.
MARIA: DO YOU THINK YOU’RE GOING
TO NEED TO THE PRESIDENT WILL
NEED TO MOBILIZE THE MILITARY TO
CREATE HOSPITAL BEDS?
I KNOW WE’VE GOT A LOT OF
SHORTAGES INCLUDING HOSPITAL
BEDS AS THESE NUMBERS SPIKE.
ARE YOU GOING TO NEED IS THE
PRESIDENT GOING TO NEED TO
MOBILIZE THE MILITARY FOR THIS?
>> WELL THE ONE THING THAT WE
COULD DO, THERE IS A BILL BY DR.
BURGESS THAT YOU BRING IN
THE RESERVE MEDICAL INTO HELP IN
THAT INSTANCE.
YOU WANT TO MAKE SURE YOU
PROTECT AND THE OTHER ELEMENT
INSIDE THIS BILL I DID NOT TALK
ABOUT YOU WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE HAVE MORE MAPS ESPECIALLY FOR
ALL OF THOSE IN THE MEDICAL,
SO THEY ARE PROTECTED.
BUT THIS BILL ALLOWED THEM TO
ACTUALLY PRODUCE MILLIONS MORE
THAN INDUSTRIAL LEVEL VERSION
THAT CAN HELP THOSE IN THE
MEDICAL INDUSTRY AND NOW
THEY CAN SELL THEM TO THEM, SO
THERE’S MANY DIFFERENT ELEMENTS
OF THIS BILL THAT PROTECTS US
EVEN FURTHER.
AND THESE ARE THE PLANNINGS THAT
WE ARE TAKING.
UNFORTUNATELY WE TRY TO GET THAT
SUPPLEMENT ALL BUT DEMOCRATS
SAID NO EARLIER.
MARIA: CONGRESSMAN GOOD TO HAVE
YOU ON THE PROGRAM THANKS VERY
MUCH FOR YOUR EFFORTS.
>> THANK YOU, MARIA.